he first looks at his december schedule
and he may not want to look at this
december schedule because it's not not
nearly as favorable as last year's
it's important to get out of the gates
strong now the ravens are a team that
can overcome a rocky start they're
established they're they're and they
they don't have many rocky starts but
for teams with new coaches teams with
young quarterbacks new systems trying to
get people to buy in trying to establish
something you don't want to trip and
fall week after week after week and go
0-3-0 and 4-1-4 whatever so early
schedule chris
vitally important to a lot of teams we
had yesterday our draft the teams that
that most need to have a strong
september september in many respects
sets the tone for the rest of the year
it does you know we've talked about it a
lot i know i don't want to you know beat
a dead horse here but yeah it can frame
your mind really it's it's it's really
only it's to me like if you really look
at it teams that are
willing or able to overcome you know
tough september's tough first four or
five weeks they're almost all
traditionally two like the teams that
you know have been there and done that a
little bit there is you know a
quarterback who's been to the playoffs a
bunch a coach that's battle tested and
that type of stuff too
it's really really rare when it's the
wait it's a second year head coach and a
first you know first time starter on our
team those teams don't ever really
bounce back from those bad starts of the
year so that's why yeah it's important
for most of the league that doesn't have
that huge big time franchise quarterback
and a and a battle-tested head coach
yeah uh so let's talk about some of the
teams that have easy starts and
difficult starts we've already hit on
the buccaneers in the chief's early
schedule the buccaneers play just one
playoff team from 2020 in their first
six games that is good for the
buccaneers
you flip it over to the kansas city
chiefs however they've got playoff teams
from last year in five of their first
seven and chris you pointed out they
could they could stumble a little bit
they could lose a few and it doesn't
take many losses to put you in grave
danger of not getting the only buy
available in the conference yeah and
listen i don't know i mean again i
expect kansas city to be you know
towards the cream of the crop when it's
all said and done at the top of the nfl
but like last year i went into the year
just feeling like
man they won the super bowl they're
gonna relish the pressure they're such
showman andy reed's not like a pressure
have his foot on your throat type of
coach every day of the year all the time
i thought they would go 14 and 2 and 15
and 1.
i don't know this year the way i look at
it it's you know three years in a row of
deep play-off runs
and i does the luster fall off i do
think there's a little bit of a chance
to where maybe they you know fall asleep
at the wheel a little bit early on worn
out by just the last three years of
being the biggest show in the nfl and
everything like that with that schedule
what's happened to them in recent
history rebounding from a super bowl
loss i ca i could kind of see them
stumbling a little bit out of the blocks
here this year
and and think about it two straight
super bowls afc championship right all
that extra football
potentially takes a toll that's one of
the things that's been so impressive
about the patriots they're run from 2011
through 2018
at least getting to the afc championship
game every year getting to the super
bowl what six times in that window
five or six times in that window that
that five i think three times two losses
five yeah that's a lot of extra football
you've got to recover from yeah that's a
lot i remember after the panthers made
it one time ron rivera was very
concerned about the offseason program
and you know how we're going to get our
guys ready because we played extra
football this year patriots do it every
year and the chiefs are now doing it
every year yeah but you know chris
something you said last hour
the fact the chiefs kind of do go up and
down to the level of the competition
they find a way
really one of the reasons the super bowl
even though the final score was 31-9 it
didn't feel like it it was because for
three and a half quarters yeah there was
still that that sense they're gonna come
back that the chiefs are gonna figure
something out because they always do
right no you're right they they are this
that's the ultimate nine lives football
team
and
even though it was 31-9 i mean we could
take three plays where the ball bounces
off the face of chiefs receivers and go
if kelsey the one of the best tight ends
in the history of football tyree kill
one of the best receivers we've seen in
football over the last 10 years if they
just catch a ball that hits them in the
face and then i believe it was the
running back uh maybe daryl williams or
somebody later in the game when mahomes
made that unbelievable throw i mean
those those catches right there it's
three plays and you go
whoa it's gonna be a maybe a one score
game and can my homes make magic they
just didn't play their best football
but like you've said so many times
usually when they don't play their best
football they make a few handful of
plays to still help them win the game
and they just didn't do that in the
super bowl but you're that's what's
great about watching them it is it's
something easier
schedules yeah for 2021. your san
francisco 49ers regardless of who's
playing quarterback whether it's jimmy
garoppolo trey lance or aaron rodgers
i'm kidding about that one i think
although there's you know still a chance
there's no other
wouldn't that be crazy and look i don't
put anything past the 49ers
right now because at times i think the
plan is there is no plan and they just
make it up as they go and if aaron
rodgers would potentially fall into
their laps so be it um
okay the 49ers
schedule begins at the lions it's the
biggest spread in week one
seven and a half point favorites against
the detroit lions uh
i even though we don't know who the
starting quarterback is going to be i
guess i'm not surprised by that because
the lines are clearly a work in progress
yeah they're a work in progress uh you
know the 49ers defense even with all the
injuries last year was still one of the
10 best defenses in football and now you
got nick bosa back and jaquaski tart and
you know they're going to have some
other guys they sign through free agency
and things like that through offense
mike when you talk about the 49ers
offensive line top five in football you
know those running backs debo samuel iu
kittle everything like that and you look
at those first two games and you go
man
if there was
any way you felt like you wanted to
start trey lance
and kind of like hey go
hey these aren't gonna be like the
toughest defenses in football we're
going to play this year we know that man
the lions and eagles
that could make you think to maybe you
could go with that rookie starting
quarterback i'm still really interested
to see what my man shanahan does at this
quarterback situation uh because you've
heard my concerns with trey lance he
hasn't played a lot of football you know
i and i err on getting these guys out
there and play and get those reps uh i
just want to see how he does this
quarterback shuffle
a couple of road games to start the year
it makes you wonder will they stay in
the east coast like they tend to do when
they have back to back yeah that's right
this side of the country their home
opener sunday night football week three
against the green bay packers
aaron rodgers made playing that game one
way or the other wouldn't that be
something
wouldn't that be it's not gonna happen
but it's fun to think about no it's not
gonna happen i mean you know not that
he'd play for the 49ers i i would say if
anything i i am i don't know what what
percentage would you put right now
rogers is going to play i i feel like
it's 85 percent he'll be there yeah i
i'm gonna even go higher than that i
just feel like with like the last two
you know john [ __ ] interviews we've seen
a few things i've seen with james jones
on the nfl network like yeah i'm almost
at like 90 95 he's gonna come back to
green bay
um he's gonna play awesome football he's
gonna make the front office miserable
and he's gonna leave town after the
year's over uh but but yeah that's hey
week three we're gonna see what the
49ers are all about the packers you know
this is what their third year in a row
having to go out there uh and deal with
this football team so that'll be a good
one on sunday night football for sure
and and uh depending upon what happens
with the pandemic it could be the first
game at levi's stadium with fans since
the nfc championship 2019 when the 49ers
blew out the green bay packers to
advance to the super bowl so uh not not
exactly the ideal time for the packers
to return to the bay area and we saw it
that year you know anytime they pack up
and go to california they get their
butts kicked it happened twice against
san francisco yeah it happened against
the chargers uh that's that's a problem
the packers are gonna have to solve
early and the 49ers even though it's not
an easy game uh you know they could they
could start off three and oh and i think
personally to stay healthy hey if they
start off healthy
that they
the the the look last year it all fell
apart early week two against the jets by
or was it week three by then yeah it was
week three yeah week two it was week two
it was jets giants back to back weeks
week two jets they came to the
greenbrier stayed the week and then it
was week three giants
it all just fell apart and they could
never get it going and there's like we
said earlier you know one of these teams
that has five primetime games is gonna
have that happen and chances are it
won't happen again to the 49ers no i i
don't see it happening i mean again i
just
would you know the sat the fact that
they resigned trent williams got alex
mack at center drafted a second round
guard to an already really talented
offensive football team and then you're
gonna have nick bosa back and everything
like that like i'm with you mike the
team's just they're they're too damn
good you know it was a top 15 offense
last year that i would just be shocked
if it's not much bet much better this
year because of the players and of
course the quarterback situation we
don't expect to see cj beathard or nick
mullins and then you know the defense
was top five last year too so yeah they
have a little bit of a early season
cushion where they can get to two-and-oh
and then stuff starts to get real a
little bit with the packers seahawks
cardinals and a bye week but yeah i
fully expect the 49ers to be
uh a major player again but that that
week three sunday night football game
that could get personal too you know
again according to how the coaches in
green bay feel about you know how
aggressively maybe the 49ers approached
uh you know the the rogers co the trade
conversation and all that stuff there i
mean we've heard that people there are
not real happy in the front office and
feel like the 49ers tampered a little
bit
the ravens have a schedule that as we
discussed earlier consists of a week two
game against the chiefs on sunday night
football but the other three of their
first four games all on the road but
games you look at and say
those are winnable at the raiders week
one yeah it's gonna be the first game at
allegiant stadium with fans but the
ravens are in a higher class than the
raiders at the lions at the broncos
those are games the ravens should win
they should be
at least three and one right heading
into a week four or week five excuse me
showdown with the team that used to be
in baltimore yeah i mean i i their
schedule is one of those ones the first
time i looked at it i went ah
that's not bad
you know i mean again there's no
there's no definitive like
real hard stretch in the first half of
the season i think that's the thing that
i look at kind of like you just said
mike i mean even with that colts week
five matchup then you got the chargers
who are you know up and coming and get
the bangles and the vikings who you know
yes the ravens should be better than the
bengals and the vikings no doubt i have
no problem saying that here in the
middle of may um so it is a a good
schedule for them to really kind of get
a stranglehold maybe on the afc north or
just play positioning in the first half
of the year with that schedule
and they better do what they can because
look at the stretch starting in yeah
really week 12. browns at steelers at
browns packers
at bengals rams steal that's legit that
that is a gauntlet i mean you've got
you've got your four games against your
two toughest rivals all packed in
to that seven game stretch to end the
season that is not going to be easy no
not easy i mean even that you know the
easy one on there is at the bengals and
you know cincinnati they're they're not
going to be just a a
pushover at home especially but yeah
that's going to be that's going to be
the season right there probably the
season and where exactly they're ranked
as far as the division standings and the
conference standings i mean that's some
big time football the fact that you got
to play
you know all those teams
the steelers and the browns four times
coming down what is that the last seven
games of the year of major implications
you know it reminds me wasn't it the
49ers last year that had that seven game
stretch that was just murderers row i
think it was the 49ers
um yes it just but just one after
another after another after another and
that contributed with all those injuries
to the thing falling apart the jag well
let's go to the panthers first the
panthers they play one playoff team from
last year in the first 10 games not that
that matters much because there are
plenty of teams that are going to make
the playoffs that didn't make it last
year i mean you look at some of these
teams they're not cupcakes they get the
jets right out of the gates which is
good if you want to get the jets you
want to get them early before they
develop into whatever they're going to
be without coach and a new quarterback
and sam darnold gets his revenge the
saints the next week that's not ideal
but it's a division game they play them
tough then they have at houston which
yeah hey you know houston many
think will be the worst team in the nfl
this year right dallas philadelphia
minnesota giants falcons i don't care
that none of those teams made it to the
playoffs those are not going to be easy
games no they're not going to be easy
carolina's still winning they're
learning how to win football games you
know there is something to that
learning how to win games in the nfl for
a young team a young coach all those
type of things so yeah nothing's a slam
dunk but like what popped up to me to
this schedule just because of you know
you the the stuff you said yesterday
where it's it is this is the exact
poster child of a team where you go
oh
wait some early season favorable
matchups to where they could gain a
little confidence and yeah cowboys and
texans defense were sucky ducky last
year they couldn't get any worse and
houston i don't expect them to be much
better dallas okay a little bit but i do
think at least like you look at that
there like you said and you rattle off
the teams you did you know there's some
winnable opportunities you don't look at
it and go no
the panthers are the lesser team you go
oh no the panthers actually might be
better and at the very worst other than
the saints game you just go it's 50 50.
so that's something and they got some
young talent that they might be able to
capitalize on something there
but you said it learning how to win
that's what they needed and have the
opportunities to do it early on the
jaguars learning how to do a lot of
things urban meyer his debut in the nfl
in any capacity they start at the texans
hey only thing better than that would be
hosting the texans to start the season
because the texans are the team to beat
literally in the nfl this year and the
jaguars could get to 1-0 just like last
year 1-0 oh wait then you lose your next
15. well hopefully it'll go better for
them after week one if they pull off a
victory in week one against the houston
texas they got denver arizona and
cincinnati to finish out the first four
and uh
look again broncos we don't
arizona's no no cupcake no the bengals
have joe burrow but uh
you know at some point the jaguars got
to line up and play games with urban
meyer and trevor lawrence and
tim tebow if he makes the 53-man roster
or the practice squad and is elevated
every week to the 55-man roster which is
what i think will happen regardless at
some point they got to play games at
some point the hype is over and we got
to see what they can do and it'll be fun
to see it'll be an interesting
laboratory experiment because we've seen
plenty of these college coaches fail
everyone wants to be jimmy johnson and
odds are eventually there will be
another jimmy johnson and until he
doesn't become the next jimmy johnson
there's a chance urban meyer could be no
i mean it it gives them a fighting
chance you know just like we talked
about with carolina it's the same thing
they got a fighting chance to kind of
get off on the right foot you know
believe in urban meyer the things he's
doing and applying to the culture of the
team everything like that it does and
like yeah i mean i i'm with you mike i
think we both look at denver to go like
denver could be one of those teams that
can make a serious jump and you said it
arizona's no like cupcake here um but at
the at the very least they their first
four games between the bango's cardinals
broncos and texans they're not
outclassed by any stretch of the
imagination so yes they should have
their opportunities to win their share
there or at least even go two and two i
mean if they go two and two i'm going
that's a positive good for urban meyer
good for trevor lawrence things are
going the right way you know we expect
them to lose games but you get out of
september two and two that'll be you
know i think people in jacksonville
would take that
yeah uh
and also it's borough versus lawrence
thursday night football week four oh
number one picks from each of the last
two years you know
in recent years you would look at
jaguars bengals in a prime time slot and
you'd say are you kidding me but hey
that's right that could get interesting
yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports